now we just talked about it minus where  the first game tomorrow you're gonna  face pragnanda again and that's a big  moment for him uh what will it be like  for you after uh losing to him in the  previous tournament  i won the tournament though that is very  true  no i mean he plays very well uh and uh  obviously um there was um  [Music]  yeah there was a lot of attention for  that game which i guess it's just um  uh good for good for chess uh but he  seemed to um  take it very very calmly which i thought  was uh was a good sign yeah don't  um don't care get carried away even if  uh people around you  you do um but um yeah he's he's doing  doing well now and he's certainly uh  a master candidate to um  to qualify for knockouts now yeah